[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاحجار الكريمه هي مواد طبيعيه حولتها
الظروف المناخيه القاسيه الى نفائسه نادره
سميت بالاحجار لان اغلبها من الاحجار
وسميت كريمه لانها مكرمه لدى النفوس ليش
لجمالها وندرتها ومن اوائل الشعوب الذي
استخدموها في ملبوسهم وحلوهم وعصيهم
وخناجرهم هم العرب ومن شده تعلقهم اسمو
ياقوت ومرجان ولؤلؤه قال تعالى يخرج منها
اللؤلؤ والمرجان وقال كانهم الياقوت
والمرجان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاحجار الكريمه تنقسم الى قسمين اولا
ذات اصل عضوي وهي التي تنشا من كائن حي يا
قرن يا ناب او داخل صدفه اللؤلؤه
والمرجانه ثانيا ذات اصلا طبيعي وهي عباره
عن احجار عاشت تحت ظروف مناخيه قاسيه
لملايين السنين كالالماس والزممرده وتبتسم
الاحجار كريمه بنقاء لونها وجمال شكلها
وخفه وزنها ما استوصف الناس عن شيء يروقهم
الا ارى ام عمر فوق ما وصفوا كانها مزنه
غراء واضحه او دره لا يوارثه الصدفه
[موسيقى]